[Música]
as mortes mais significativas guarda da
escola com mais de humor ficam aquelas
foram vividas na natureza é impossível
esquecer todos os momentos vividos no em
contato natural e não lembro da agonia
dos testes nem dos três das crianças de
famílias sentem hoje posso dizer que a
minha escola pode aprender matemática
lindo por dentro de uma igreja local
aprendi a trabalhar com as mãos num tear
guarda até hoje aprendi orientação em
provas no parquímetro montinho aprendi a
viver em comunidade a nos cras
definitiva da escola sem vigilância que
qualquer adulto e aprendi sobre amizade
dos vários movimentos que vou sair e
tomar decisões nos caminhos do diário
para a escola em grupo ou sozinho e
também em inventar certas desculpas para
as calças rasgadas por a terra nas mãos
e para as marcas negras do corpo que o
privilégio ter contato natural e metrô
primeira empresa do meio pequeno e não
vai sair infância é brincar na rua
literalmente não tínhamos grandes coisas
sem grande brinquedos mas ninguém no
mundo
não tínhamos grandes coisas mas o metrô
era completamente é que nós
necessitávamos
para fazer comida brincar
lana fogo e tantas coisas que me
permitiam brincar e uma forma natural
nos melhores dias
era o que eu tinha que provar que
brincar e não têm aulas como é óbvio
brincar completamente neve todo o dia
com leve muitas vezes até os joelhos e
não tinha roupa tem os preços que a
oprah ter contato com ele mas não sentia
qualquer frio
lembro e sinto que aprendi que é natural
a natureza ea origem e que oficial é
aquilo que nós criamos todos nós criamos
um ser humano certa forma sentir
primeiro contato com a natureza
eu tirava sentia que a aprendizagem
certa forma estava completamente nu do
metrô também origem e pensava de
aprender num ambiente completamente essa
estava do natural da nossa origem
lembro de um cantos cinzento cimento era
praticamente um pouco utilizado e se eu
era quem mais uma função estética então
era assim que podemos aprender
sustentabilidade em ambientes
completamente insustentável mas nem
tanto tempo desta faz uma coisa muito
importante e que de certa forma uma
corda coisa de importante também levando
da paixão de muitos professores na
transmissão do seu conhecimento e essas
coisas não se esquecem ficam para sempre
me fazem sentir sentir aproximamos da
nossa natureza
de origem no entanto posso dizer que a
minha vida mudou
não me tirar e o contato com a central
também mudou de tal forma que ao
terminar a licenciatura
eu segui certa forma se evitarão meu
percurso académico por cria conectar com
a natureza procurar outros fronts fonte
de aprendizagem e pesar até algumas
opiniões profissionais bastante
interessantes seria já certa forma então
à procura do natural daquilo que faltava
petróleo natureza e este contato que eu
recordo da infância queria conhecer
pessoas viajar conhecer culturas outras
línguas outras formas de trabalhar e
aprender e de ensinar também no contexto
se calhar mais próximos do metrô
essas viagens começaram com experiência
na manhã numa escola
considero transporte muito o que permite
uma invasão do natural aviário quero a
sua arquitetura
o ambiente muito harmônica pelo corpo
com presença em ambientes naturais e
vários elementos da natureza a madeira o
pouco poste existente
os brinquedos naturais e genética feitos
à mão
esta escola foi uma das primeiras
aprendizagens uma das primeiras
experiências que voluntária grande um
ano na manhã neste mesmo ano em que
voltou a contactar com que escolas muito
em sã e já é a minha infância são
conhecidas as causas da floresta ou
fosco que existem em qualquer parte do
mundo hoje em dia em portugal também há
um grande movimento de escolas têm um
grande contato com a natureza e não há
um grande pensamento em termos de ver
grandes estruturas físicas
alguma estrutura onde seja possível
aprender é própria natureza é o caso da
aprendizagem não há limites não há
fronteiras
independente das condições climatéricas
podemos é incrível poder deixar
assentado em troncos debaixo de chuva é
muito minha mas também construir
campanhas com rech troxas para
discutirmos chuva muito intensa e do
frio ou então de agradecer num circo
garantiram o dia vivido esse contato com
o petróleo é fantástico que pode ser
fantástico
vocês últimos anos é visitar escolas com
pedagogias diferenciadas mais holística
digamos que eu vi um sujeito em nome do
hotel é o nome estranho sair tem de
visitar várias escolas em todo mundo
incluindo portugal
então passei mais de uma década a
visitar mais 37
eu tive todos os projetos foram
escolhidos com alguma intenção ea
intenção foi procurar o natural do que
realmente eu sentia falta são projetos
que enviarem trazem para seu nome
educativo e tentou enquadrar o metrô no
seio artificial com tantas vantagens é o
caso do atlântico em bali na indonésia
construída com mais sete quilômetros de
ambos em parafuso como a ventilação
natural e sem iluminação artificial uma
escola funciona quase exclusivamente com
energia no valor de ontem sem conceito
muito importantes escolas em paredes do
google apresenta diário assim como
também um ambiente livre de sapatos
outro é sanborn antiga que é uma arte
marcial praticada na lama onde se cobra
nozes e uma disciplina pode ser optativa
em que no decorrer do dia infância
no entanto aprender a lidar com as
cobras
este time faria para saber estar nestes
ambientes e as crianças adoram outros
conceitos dessa escola é o conceito
polícia 10 em que são organizadas de
alimentos e como parte do currículo
escolar
fox ou encaminhadas para apanhar o lixo
e conversar
este lixo é transformado por que é
vendido é limpo e seco e transformava em
palestras que também se pode aprender
dinda que vem o suor ficou subindo
palmeiras com mais de cinco metros de
altura e arquitetura e sustentável
não há uma separação entre o que é
natural e que é criado o homem árvores
dentro e fora das estruturas da escola
já os nossos corpos seguem se constrói
através de estruturas físicas as
estruturas da escola ou com as todas
posso dizer que são uma tradução dos
organismos vivos que existem na natureza
esta sala tartaruga
as crianças podem brincar aprender a
cuidar das suas plantas de estimação
as calças ea casa das fadas onde podem
entrar várias diligências no mundo de
hoje
os cometem para os benefícios do contato
com o metrô e acho que é evidente quando
nos lembramos de uma caminhada que
fizemos no fim de semana passado
sentimos diferentes mas também há muitas
evidências e com todo o mérito de tudo o
que eu tenho sido criado o homem inicia
e havia seis aviões de 13 anos que já vi
no livro com seu mundo
não podemos com atrações outras do amor
não poderíamos beneficiar o
desenvolvimento tecnológico da medicina
o parecer seja se o tantas vidas humanas
sem salva ou também as tecnologias e as
novas formas de comunicação das quais
nos associamos de alimentos porque
raramente temos comunicarem de forma
distante com o mundo inteiro e
transmitir algo que ele tropas nossos
sentimentos das pessoas que mais demanda
natural para mim significou muitos
significou tudo
no entanto o filho na escola educativo
onde um quilíbrio entre o metrô e
oficial possa existir em 2017 voltar a
me ensinar e por participar no festival
de arte urbana
propus um exercício comunitário
inspirava autorizada e adaptado de um
trabalho artístico com uma grande
componente social e comunitária
existentes em vários países um exercício
muito importante porque como irá
envolver e partilhar sonhos experiências
ambições e também preocupações nessa
altura eu pensei neste exercício também
em termos pessoais e daquilo que eu
gostaria de ver no mundo
já nessa altura também qualquer criança
neste mundo pudesse ter acesso a uma
escola e quer conhecer e aprender como é
que eu tive quando era criança e também
ter o acesso iso fluir da maravilha que
mundo artificial que o desporto que as
várias coisas e tantas criações que o
homem queria estar presente nesta
aprendizagem
lembro um grande professor da
universidade de cavaco silva
campeã um pouco presta um treino oficial
no metrô e eu vou dizer uma coisa que
ficou até hoje de aprendizagem cognitiva
tiveram um peso muito estilo
durante nosso período na escola e ao
longo da vida foi reduzida a um mero
quanto a isto poderemos vir a observar é
seres humanos como robôs que mil won
sei-hoon podem ser mentalmente insanos
o meu sonho por fios convosco é criar
uma escola do leste em portugal possa
estar conectado com o mundo do
equilíbrio entre o natural e artificial
possa conviver em harmonia
[Aplausos]